you guys it's devin and tan
90 day fiance star devin clegg reveals
some heartbreaking news about her son
revealing on instagram tuesday that her
three-year-old son taeyeon has cancer
[Music]
devin shared a series of photos of
taeyeon in the hospital and explained
that he's undergone multiple procedures
and started chemotherapy just days ago
in the caption she writes in part my
beloved son taehyung who just celebrated
his third birthday last month was just
diagnosed with childhood cancer b-cell
acute lymphoblastic leukemia just a few
days ago this is every parent's absolute
worst nightmare and i'm trying hard to
stay strong for taehyung drusilla and my
baby in my tummy
[Music]
and despite taeyong's devastating
diagnosis devin is remaining hopeful for
the future the reality star who is
currently pregnant with her third child
with boyfriend topper park set up a
gofundme to help with taeyong's medical
expenses and she's getting support from
her 90-day fiance fam
stephanie motto wrote sending so much
love to you guys here for you girl
corey rathgiber shared i hope all goes
well
while larissa lima said she's praying
for your family
[Music]
the day jihoon was actually leaving for
korea i did not feel good
and he made the joke you know maybe
you're pregnant
i take the test
instantly two lines which is positive
you'll recall the salt lake native and
jihoon met online and found out they
were expecting taehyung on the show he
did not believe me
and he went into the bathroom
and made me pee in front of him don't
blame him
such a short period of time you want to
make sure
six positive tests later
i i'm pregnant
[Music]
i instantly assumed i would never see
jihyun again
but when jihoon actually got back to
korea the first text message they got
from him was saying
well we have to get married now
let's figure it out the pair has since
called it quits devin is now with topher
park and spends a lot of time together
as a family along with devin's eldest
child daughter driscilla from a previous
relationship the couple suffered a
miscarriage in 2021 but revealed some
good news earlier this month they're
expecting a baby together
our thoughts and prayers are with the
entire family
[Music]
you